the Joe Rogan experience how do you get
kickboxing to be big in America why
can't they figure that out um doesn't
make any goddamn sense no I think in my
I think because MMA I think it's I think
because there's college wrestling I
think it's stock as well you know the
box in America is always a great box
there's no I said boxing fights but I
think it may be because of the college
wrestling because it's more of what you
used to Howard's wrestling what do you
mean well he wrestled on these
wrestling's popular you know what I mean
in colleges and stuff like that so I
think they've kind of taught to that or
maybe it's a new sport and they've
grabbed onto it and it's they've kind of
got it as theirs cuz I'm amazed really
the UFC is like what if wouldn't got
over here though with their MMA and mix
sure yeah and then if you're sat there
waiting for MMA it come on but in
between that you see some [ __ ] crazy
Thai fight with two people going at a in
four ounce clothes or in a proper war
that might help if they did someone like
that did not I mean then you got like
the average Joes never seen it before
thinking whoa what would that and I've
never seen none before I like that so
maybe something like that like some
mixtures with it like what one do that's
why there's someone for everyone on
themselves
well muy Thai and kickboxing doesn't
suck off in England either so it's got a
lot better of it year's platform that it
should be I mean yah cow I mean your
fight with her Simba knew he's just
crazy you know what I mean or one I see
one championship fights you know we're
all would always gluten up soon as if
it's on was strapped with our phones and
watching it so it's a shame really
hey Sam it's a bummer in America yeah
you know Dana White had a really
interesting point he said we got ruined
in the 1980s with
pka karate yeah like these that PK
karate and you know there was some guys
are really exciting like Rick Rufus yeah
but a lot of it was [ __ ] it was like
boring kicks above the waist yeah and
they weren't that good they either would
just throw a couple kicks and then
shitty boxing Steve super k quick he was
killed Wallace Wallace but there was
some costly pick a quick
don't have any weapon in England though
we got we got
mate I'm on TV and I don't know it war
would chose device the chose shit-faced
upon oh really no one's gonna be
interested in watching him if you're
gonna like get a spot you need to put
out there like pre-recorded shores of
the best fights and put them on just to
get some interest yeah and then maybe
people just start taking a bit more
noise but we had like if you like
splice on Sky Sports and the put [ __ ]
face on yeah cuz there's so much great
talent Nagata there Mike whenever I
watched glory I mean I stop and think
I'm like how is this not enormous like
there's so many boxing fights that are
kind of boring yet true and then you
watch this and like Jesus Christ is so
much more exciting exactly and I can't
get my head around it and even after
that fight in Cambodia iodide it for six
days I'm after that not only a six round
fight that's why I fought and won that
were boring I didn't like your head hit
and two got a take for six days I'm
never doing this again because you're
taking more shots to the hair yeah
everybody's any clothes and stuff it's
all like mmm I just didn't do it for me
I appreciate boxing I do love watching
instead of poor Muay Thai Yankees
whereby I say the reality is if any
elite boxer decided to fight in elite
Muay Thai fighter if they're getting
[ __ ] up you have a couple seconds to
close the distance mike tyson stop yeah
and put that dude away raja get you like
pluck he'll like blasted i mean i would
like to see I would have loved to see a
guy like Mike Tyson in his prime if they
if there was a guy like Rico or some
level kickboxer who could potentially
[ __ ] him up on the way in you know
though someone like Rico's got good
kicks and good knees for such a big guy
as well it became no chance I don't
think Mike Tyson comes close that day
you never know
well did you see when Mike Tyson and
John Jones was messing about like play
sort of sparring and you could see the
right hand a ball money stick and also
that's a 50 year old Mike Tyson together
true yeah yeah it's just when he was
young like when you remember the Marvis
Frazier fight yeah yeah that was like
waving them in anyways flop execution
yeah just stepped in and just I was
thinking like what if someone wasn't
gonna leak kickboxer would you be able
to hold that guy off like that one like
that with the Mike Tyson in his prime
when he was storming his way towards the
title all true
you'd have to clinch yeah yeah I am open
elbow knee no is that quick fast and try
and grab him that's coming over top but
some guys did manage to make it to the
final bell with them like there's some
guys that managed to survive yet so nice
mocha yeah 20 Tasha Smith yeah there's a
few guys there was a few gobbled him is
all you know that was a right under the
knee just wobbled dips is like
commercial Smith as a powerful do yet he
was yeah yeah cause he beat Frank Bruno
then he's the first person to knock out
Frank Bruno front people coming every
weight then yeah
[Applause]